we have some major major news about the
sony disney deal in regards to
spider-man but this news does not just
affect spider-man this news could affect
the entirety of the MCU it could change
the MCS course how's it going everybody
it's Warren and I know it's been quite a
ride over the past month with this sony
disney deal in the fight over spider-man
there have been a ton of reports that
have gone back and forth we have public
statements from both Sony and Disney
regarding the situation and the deal has
been closed and opened again and closed
again a few different times and right
now it is being reported that the deal
between Disney and Sony is on hold but
the reason that it is on hold is really
really good news for Disney and Marvel
and could possibly mean the return of
spider-man to the MCU but not just
spider-man venom and carnage as well so
I'll explain everything that you need to
know about this deal in this video but
first a quick reminder I'm giving away
an Xbox one or a ps4 at 550,000
subscribers I already gave away one at
500,000 subscribers I started the new
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain so there
has been a lot of talk recently about
Apple buying Sony now on the surface you
may not think that this has anything to
do with the Sony Disney deal about
spider-man but I assure you it very much
does so a few days ago an investor
analyst said that a big acquisition
looks to be on the horizon for Apple and
he listed a few companies that are
potential candidates for the acquisition
and Sony Pictures was listed on there
and they aren't the only companies that
may be interested in purchasing Sony
Amazon is on the looks to purchase them
as well and possibly Netflix and since
this news has come out it has been
reported originally I think by Lords of
the long box that the Sony Disney deal
is on hold and this makes perfect sense
on Disney's part and I'll explain why in
the contract of spider-man and all of
the characters that involve spider-man
such as venom and carnage it states that
if Sony Pictures is ever sold the film
rights to spider-man and the rest of
them go back to Disney and Marvel and
that is according to Forbes dot-com so
what that means is if
Apple or Amazon or Netflix by Sony
that means the rights to spider-man and
all of the other characters go back to
Marvel and Disney this means that if
Apple buys Sony Pictures spider-man and
venom and carnage and everybody else
associated with them go back to Marvel
and Disney for free so with all these
reports and talked about Sony possibly
being bought by another company of
course it makes sense that Disney and
Marvel put the deal on hold they're not
going to make a deal with Sony Pictures
for spider-man if they could be getting
spider-man back for free not too long
from now and obviously this opens up
such a huge potential for the MCU venom
could start to appear in the MCU carnage
could appear in the MCU as well and we
could see spider-man and venom in a film
not only that but other things such as
the Venom symbiote taking over Deadpool
which is something that has happened in
the comics that everybody has loved the
potential really is just amazing for the
future of the MCU if this happens so
right now it's kind of just a waiting
game to see if any of these companies
are actually going to buy Sony again it
makes perfect sense that Marvel and
Disney would want to wait to find out
what happens because they could get
spider-man back for free so it's looking
like everything could work out for
spider-man in the MCU after all you
never know with these big businesses but
hopefully it works out so let me know
how excited you would be to get
spider-man venom and carnage in the MCU
of this deal pans out let me know your
thoughts in the comments and also don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof